[موسيقى]
توفيقه بينما تحدث اليكم الان
تتفاعلوا اخرى ونبدا من بروكسيل الخلافات
على قمه الدول الاتحاد الاوروبيه
على روسيا
من لندن تفصلنا هذه الصور في يوم اضراب
لتواقم التمريض هي هو الاكبر منذ تاسيسه
تاسيس هيئه الصحه العامه البريطانيه
مطالبين بتحسين ظروف العمل
[موسيقى]
ايضا من بيروت نتابع هذه الصور بعد مقتل
جندي ايرلندي واصابه اخر اثر اطلاق نار
وانقلاب السياره لقوات الامم المتحده لحفظ
السلام في لبنان اليوم في بلده العاقبيه
الجنوبيه البلاد
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
مساعي تحديد سعر الغاز وفرض عقوبات على
روسيا تعمق خلافات الاوروبيين
ضروره هزيمه ارهاب الطاقه الروسيه بكل
اشكاله وبوتين يقول ان بلاده تتعرض لعدوان
غير مسبوق لتقويه اقتصادها
مع التوجه واشنطن لتزويده بمنظومه
الصواريخ الدفاعيه اوكرانيا تعلن ان روسيا
قصفت اراضيها بالصواريخ اس 3
امريكي مباشر في الحرب
بعد سبيع من تجميدها روسيا وتركيا تستنفان
دورياتهم المشتركه الشماليه سوريا
واردوغان يقول ان بلاده ستقوم بما يلزم
للدفاع عن نفسها اذا استمرت واشنطن في دعم
ما يسميها منظمات ارهابيه
مع بدي تصويت التونسيين في الخارج الدعوه
لمقاطعه الانتخابات التشريعيه تتجدد
والبرلمان الاوروبي يقرر عدم ارسال بعثه
لمراقبه الانتخابات التونسيه الرئيس سعيد
يرفض انتقادات الامريكيه لتوسيع صلاحيته
واجابه الخاص تقول ان حل الازمه يكمن في
حوار وطني شامل
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا روبيه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا القرار الذي اتخذه صندوق
النقد الدولي بان الغى من جدوى لاعمال
مجلس ادارته اجتماعا مع تونس كان مقررا في
التاسعه عشر من الشهر الجاري صندوق النقد
الدولي كان قد اعلن في اكتوبر الماضي
الاتفاق مع تونس على منحها قرضا بقمه
مليار و900 مليون دولار دعما للسياساتها
الاقتصاديه اذا اقره المجلس التنفيذي
للصندوق
رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما دوافع صندوق النقد
الدولي لالغاء مناقشه قرض تونس دعم
الاقتصادها
51% ارجع الامر الى عدم ثقه صندوق النقد
في السلطات التونسيه بينما ارجعه 35
بالمئه الى ازمه البلاد السياسيه وقال 14%
ان السبب هو اجراءات اداريه على مستوى
صندوق النقد الدولي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات من
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز الكيوار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاءنا في المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونناقشه خلاله قضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
في بريطانيا يخوضون اضرابا هو الاكبر في
تاريخ البلاد المطالب هي رفع الاجور
وتحسين الظروف العمل
[موسيقى]
بعد الحصاد مباشره نتابع الثانيه عشر وخمس
دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه الجوله الرياضيه
اليوميه يوميات المونديال ترصد مستجدات
كاس العالم قطر 20022
[موسيقى]
اتفق القاده الاوروبيون خلال اجتماعي قمه
في بروكسل على اعتماد الحزمه التاسعه من
العقوبات ضد روسيا بسبب حربها على
اوكرانيا
الاوروبيون على تكليف وزراء الطاقه ببحث
التوافقي على تحديد سقف لسعر الغاز بعد
وزراء الطاقه جاء دور على قاره الدول
السبع والعشرين لتظهر لتظهر خلافتهم بهذا
الخصوص في قمهم الاخيره هذا العام
ويقول الرئيس الروسي في المقابل انما يجري
انما هو عدوان غير مسبوق على بلاده هدفه
الاساسي تقويده الاقتصاد الروسي
في اخر اجتماعي لهم هذا العام الذي يسعون
فيه قدر الامكان لاظهار الوحده في وجه
روسيا تفرق خلافات عده قاده الاتحاد
الاوروبي اخفق وزراء الطاقه قبيل القمه في
التوصل الى اجماع بشان وضع سقف لاسعار
الغاز ترفض دور على راسها المانيا هذا
السقف خوف من توجه المنتجين الى اسواق
اخرى قدمت المفوضيه الاوروبيه اقتراحا
اعتبرت الدور المطالبه بوضع هذا السقف انه
يتضمن شروط صارمه هدفها الا يطبق على
الاطلاق رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شال ميشيل
قال ان وضع سقفي لاسعار الغاز امر المعقد
وتحدي كبير لكنه عبر عن ثقته بالقدره على
التوصل الى اتفاق تستمر هذه الخلافات في
وقت يسدد فيه الرئيس الاوكراني في قمه
القاده الاوروبيين على اهميه حرب الغاز
ستكون الاشهر السته المقبله حاسمه من
نواحي عديده في المواجهه التي بداتها
روسيا بهذا العدوان العدوان على اوكرانيا
وضد كل واحد منكم لان الهدف النهائي
لروسيا هو ابعد بكثير من حدودنا والسياده
الاوكرانيه اولا يجب هزيمه ارهاب الطاقه
الروسي بجميع اشكاله وثانيا صمود اوكرانيا
في هذا الشتاء ليس سقف اسعار الغاز
الخلافه الوحيده بين الاوروبيين فقد عطلت
بولندا حزمه مساعدات لاوكرانيا بقيمه 18
مليار يورو كما عطلت الاتفاق على الحسمه
التاسعه من العقوبات على روسيا بسبب خلاف
بشان قائمه الاسماء التي ستطلعها العقوبات
لا شك ان هذه الخلافات تلقى صدا ايجابيا
في روسيا التي ما فتات تندد بما تعتبره
حربا اقتصاديه غربيه عليها
بشكل عقوبات غير مسبوقه على روسيا كان
يهدف بشكل اساسي الى تحقيق اقتصادنا في
وقت قصير وتدمير العمله الوطنيه من خلال
سرقه احتياطياتنا من العملات الاجنبيه
واحداث ضخم المدمر هذه الحسابات كما رايتم
ونرى جميعا لم تفلح
يعول الاوروبيون على ان تؤدي الحرب
الاقتصاديه التي يتحدث عنها بوتن الى جعل
روسيا غير قادره على مواصله الحرب
العسكريه في اوكرانيا لكن الخلافات بين
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي والخلافات بين دول
الاتحاد والولايات المتحده ربما تعرقل
خططهم جميعا فالقاده الاوروبيون يناقشون
في قمهم ايضا العلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده والاجره التي اتخذتها الاداره
الامريكيه لحمايه اقتصادها والتي تضر
بالشركات الاوروبيه انها خلافات تشوش حتى
الان على الرغبه في اظهار الوحده للدروسيا
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من وارسو
رادس لايف سكور سكي وزير الخارجيه والدفاع
البولنديه السابق ومعنى من موسكو في دوره
عضو مجلس الدماء الروس يبدا بضيفي امن
وارسو وهذه الاخبار العاجله بشان اتفاق
القاده الاوروبيين على الحزمه التاسعه من
العقوبات على روسيا مع ارجاء الامر فيما
يتعلق بوضع سقف لسعر الغاز الروسي اختار
القدر الاوروبيون الحل فيما يبدو وليس
كذلك
روسيا ارتكبت تعمل
عدوانيتانه الجمعيه العامله ومتحده
وكثره حتى ضماناتها الامنيه وهيد وتقوم
حرب الايدفاده في اوكرانيا ضد البنوك
تحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا وبالتالي علينا
ان ندفع روسيه للتوقف عن ذلك وافقنا عليه
ثمان حزن
وعقوبات
لا ينبغي للرئيس يستفيد الاسعار
واللي يساعد اوكرانيا الدفاع عن نفسها ومن
الذي تم الاتفاق عليه اليوم يصب في هذا
الاتجاه باستثناء مجموعه من العقوبات التي
قيل حتى قبل اقرار انها ستكون عقوبات
شكليه اللي هي الحزن التاسع
وانا كمان
في هذا المجال ولكن
العقوبات بدات تاتي كلها
من التكنولوجيا من الرقائق
في اوروبا هو محاوله لتدمير الاقتصاد
الروسي
يعني ليس ذلك واضحا هل يحتاج ذلك الى
تصريح
اولا روسيا في هذا الحديث لم تدان من
الاتحاد الاوروبي لذلك او الامم المتحده
لذلك هي تقوم بعمليه قانونيه في مناطق
تابعه لها نحن لم ندخل الى بولندا الى دول
اخرى اوروبيه نحن ندافع عن كمال اراضينا
وسلامه اراضينا التي وصلنا اليها بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ان الاقتصاد شيء
مستقل نحن لدينا ثلث الانتاج العالمي لذلك
اي تهديد ضد الاقتصاد الروسي هذا شيء مثل
السخافه لان هذا سيف سوف يضر بمصالحهم هم
لن تستطيع العيش دون روسيا انها تحديد
او استخدام وسائل غير همم متناسبه للسوق
بتحديد الاسعار على النفط او الغاز هذا لن
يقدم اي شيء لان الغاز والنفط سوف يباع
لهذه الدول عن طريق ممرات اخرى او دول
اخرى هذه هي السوق العالميه لن تستطيع ان
تستغني عن هذا من المستحيل ان تع- يعمل
الاغتصاب العالمي دون المواد الاوليه من
روسيا من المستحيل تقسيم السوق العالميه
لذلك نحن نفهم من هذه القيود هي موجهه
ليست ضد روسيا بل هي محاوله انشاء نظام
جديد في الشبكات العالميه وهذا سوف يكون
شيء غير ناجح لان هذا شيء لن يقوم احد
بالترحيب به لان لن يقوم احد بالترحيب
بهذا على السوق العالمي للمواد الاوليه
اذا حددتم الاسعار عليكم ان تقوم بهذا في
كل مكان لان الاسعار هي موحده على
العالميه موحده همم اي اي عقوبات على
روسيا تضر بالعالم وليس فقط روسيا وجهه
النظر هذه عده اعدها الى ضيفي منوارسو
رادس لايف سكورسكي اليست هذه ايضا وجهه
نظر معتبره داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي اليست
هذه وجهه نظر المانيا وجهه نظر فرنسا وجهه
نظر دول اخرى في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان وضع
السقف لسعر الغازي الروسي امر يضر بنا
جميعا ويدفع بالرؤوس الى الذهاب الى السوق
اخرى وما اكثر هذه الاسواق
انه لك سيد
حسن
نريد
الغزو ال ال الفود هذه الحرب الاستعماريه
اثناء ذلك
ضيفي من موسكو في دوره يعني وكان ضيفنا من
همم وارسو يقول انه خيارات روسيا ايضا
محدوده فيما يتعلق بتصريف غازيها وبيعي
لانه لا توجد خيارات جاهزه اذا وضع
الاوروبيون سقفا لسعر الغاز الروسي لن
يتمكن الروس من بيعه بهذه السرعه وهذه
السهوله في اسواق اخرى
كاس
من هذا الكاس ثلث الموارد من الغاز والنفط
عندها الاقتصاد في العالم كله سوف ينقص
الى الثلثين لذلك نحن نتحدث عن هذه
العقوبات في ضوء الشهر التاسع للعمليه
العسكريه وكلنا نفهم هذا الشيء من
المستحيل ان حلم شاكل الاقتصاد العالمي
بدون المواد الاوليه الروسيه ان هذا يهدد
التوازن الاقتصادي في العالم كله لهذا نحن
ننظر الى العقوبات الاوروبيات كالشيء كاذب
ومخادع سوف نغير العمل اللوجستي ولكن لن
يستطيع الاستغناء عن المواد الاوليه
الروسيه سوف نقوم ببيعها لاسيا ثم تبيعها
اسيا لا اذا سوف يكون هناك رفع اسعار في
العمل اللوجستي والمواد الاوليه ولكن
الاستغناء عن هذه المواد شيء مستحيل لان
الاقتصاد العالمي سوف يموت دونها من موسكو
ايفيني في دوره في عضو مجلس الدماء الروسي
شكرا جزيلا لكم ونشكر ضيفنا من وارسو
راديو سلام
وزير الخارجيه والدفاع الهولنديه السابق
[موسيقى]
حضر الطي روسيا من انها لن تتردد في
استهداف اي منظومات الدفاع جوي جديده قد
تزود بها الولايات المتحده الجيش
الاوكراني ياتي هذا في ظل حديث من مسؤولين
امريكي
على تلك الصواريخ في التصدي للطائرات
المسيره والهاجمات الصاروخيه التي تشنها
موسكو على البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه بشكل
متوسط
تروح المعارك مكانها على الارض والحلو
برايكيات قد يكون في تغيير موازين القوى
في الجو ومنذ التقدم الميداني الذي حققه
الجيش الاوكراني في مقاطعه خرسون جنوب
الشرقيه البلاد قبل نحو شهر لا تكاد
الجبهات الساخنه الاخرى تشهد اختراقات
كبيره وجوهريه لاي من الطرفين رغم تمكن
القوات الروسيه والانفصاليين المواليين
لها من تحقيق مكاسب ميدانيه في مقاطعه
دميه فضلا عن مواصله قصفها لمقاطعه لوغانس
وميكولايف وزابولوجيا ودين برو لذلك
فرهانو الاوكراني حاليا يبدو منشغلا
بالحصول على سلاح النوعي جديد من الحديث
والدعم الرئيسي الاهم منذ اندلاع الحرب
الحديث هنا عن تزويد امريكي المرتقب لكييف
بمنظومه صواريخ باتريوت الدفاع الجوي خطوه
ان حصلت ستمكن الاوكرانيين من التصدي
بفعاليه اكبر للضربات الصارو والغارات
وهجمات المسيرات التي تشنها موسكو بشكل
شبه يومي وتستهدف عاده منشات البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه والتي كان اخرها القصف
العنيف الذي طال البنيه التحتيه في خاركيف
واستخدمت فيه روسيا صواريخ اس 300 بحسب
الجيش الاوكراني
كما ستمنح صواريخ باتريوت الفرصه للقوات
البريه الاوكرانيه للتحرك بحريه اكبر دون
القلق من الخطر القادم من السماء فاستعاده
الاراضي تجريب صعوبه كبيره كما يقول
الرئيس لينسكي بسبب التدمير الروسي المنهج
للمدن الاوكرانيه يقول مسؤولون امريكيون
ان واشنطن تضعوا لمساتها الاخيره على
الخطط الخاصه بتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ
باتريوت ولذلك سارعت موسكو عبر المتحدثه
باسم وزاره خارجيتها ماريا زخرفه بالتحذير
من ان المنظومه ستكون هدفا عسكريا مشروعا
للجيش الروسي وانها ستؤدي الى تصعيد
الصراع وتزيد من تورط الجيش الامريكي
المباشر في الاعمال القتاليه باوكرانيا
لكن خطط الولايات المتحده لا تقتصر فقط
على تزويد الاوكرانيين بالصواريخ باتريات
في بحسب مسؤولين امريكي فان
ستزود كييف بمعدات الكترونيه متطوره
لتحويل الذخائر الجويه غير الموجهه الى
قنابل ذكيه قادره على استهداف مواقع
عسكريه الروسيه بدقه
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
موسكوندرارتموند الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ومعنى من واشنطن الادميرال
ويليام فعلا قائد القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه السابق وقائد الاسطول الخامس
الامريكيه السابق وابدا بضيفي من موسكو
اريكساندر
حينما تقول موسكو ان
تزويده اوكرانيا بمنظومه الدفاع الجوي
الصاروخيه باتريوت يعني انخراط الولايات
المتحده في الحرب في اوكرانيا ماذا يعني
ذلك ما الذي سيترتب على ذلك ما الخطوات
التي سترد بها موسكو على ذلك
تعلموني
لا ترعبنا لاننا نعلم ان عندما عملت هذه
الصواريخ في ثلاث سنوات من قبل
وفي اليمن
وعندما كان هناك ضربات ضد السعوديه راينا
ان هذه الانظمه لن تستطيع ان تضرب وتقصف
الصواريخ التي اطلقها القوات في اليمن
لذلك نحن هادئون بالنسبه لهذه الصواريخ
التي تكلف الصاروخان واحد منها مليون
دولار هذه الاسلحه سوف تدافع عن المتخصصين
والخبراء الامريكان المتواجدون في
اوكرانيا ولن تعمل هذه الصواريخ على
الجبهات لانها مكلفه جدا لذلك نحن هذه هنا
ونفهم في نفس الوقت عن
الخبراء الامريكان هم الوحيدين القادرين
على تشغيل هذه
التاريخ لذلك سوف ننظر على هذه لهذه
الصواريخ على انها اهداف شرعيه سوف
نستهدفها وندمرها وسوف ندافع عن جميع
المنشات التابعه لنا
وليام فارس كان يبتسم حينما كان يتحدث
ضيفنا من موسكو نريد ان نعرف سبب الابتسام
اولا وثانيا ما هي الخطوات التي ستتخذها
الولايات المتحده كي لا تكون او لا تعتبر
من وجهه نظر روسيا منخرطه في الحرب
ان هذا الامر يختلف اساسا
منذ بدا روسيا بغزه روسيا
ان الله الولايات المتحده ومع الكثير من
الدول العالم
تقدم المساعدات على شكل اسلحه وتكنولوجيا
وذخائر لمساعده اوكرانيا الدفاع عن نفسها
وبالتالي هذه مجرد وسيله اخرى اضافيه
والمتحدث من روسيا نعم نعم
صواريخ غاليه الثمن ولكنها مفيده لبعض
الاغراض
بنفس الدرجه ولكن من يعلم بان اوكرانيا
وليس لدي اي فكره كم بطاريه توصل الى
اوكرانيه واي منها لهناك انواع مختلفه من
الصواريخ
ولكنها جيده لبعض الاغراض
ولكن ال- ال- المتحدث الروسي محق بانها
غاليه الثمن
اذا ما ارسلت فعلا الى اوكرانيا فعلا
نشرها
اوصي ان يكون بطريقه محسوبه بشكل دقيق
تكون ضد انواع محدده من المخاطر والتديدات
التي معينه
سبب ابتسامه فكان لحسم معلوماتي ليس لدينا
خبراء امريكان في اوكرانيا
لمساعد على استخدام
هذاكرانيه
هذا يطرح سؤال ادمن فعلا هذا يطرح سؤال عن
السيناريوهات اذا نشرت هذه المنظومه في
اوكرانيا هل يمكن ان تعمل بدون وجود خبراء
امريكيين قادرين على تشغيلها هل التدريب
للجنود الاوكرانيين الذي قيل انه يحدث في
المانيا كافن همم وهل لديكم ثقه بانه
الاوكرانيين لن يستخدمها لاغراض اخرى
اي فكره عن ما هي الحدود امكانيات وماذا
تكون النقاشات بين حكومه الاوكرانيه
والحكومه الامريكيه لكن حول السؤال لك
الاول طبعا
ما الذي يقوم بالتدريب الاستخدام هذه
الصواريخ لن يكون ناكر امريكيه تذهب الى
اوكرانيا
ليستطيع لاستخدام بشكل جيد ولكن متاكد هذا
امر تجربه مناقشته حاليا اذا ما له حقا ان
هذه المنظمات البطاريات ارسلت بعد التدريب
عليها ههه اذا وصلت لكن ايضا مما قيل هو
تحويل
القذافي الى قنابل ذكيه همم
همم ضيفنا بالماوسكو همم
اليكساندر تومورو في تقول ان موسكو غير
قلقه من الباتريوت لكن هنالك معلومات اخرى
معدات الكترونيه تحول همم قذائف عاديه الى
قنابل ذكيه يمكن ان
تستهدف القوات الروسيه الى هي مدى روسيا
قلقه ايضا من هذه المعلومات
ونلحظ هذه الانظمه في اوكرانيه سوف نستخدم
الموجات الصوتيه لتحديد مواقعها وسوف
نستخدم ضدها صواريخ الخنجر الخنجر همم
كما التي استخدمناها في غرب اوكرانيا
وتعلمون ان سرعه هذه الصواريخ اعلى سرعه
الصوت ب 10 مرات ولكن صواريخ همم اقل سرعه
بعشر مرات من هذه الصواريخ الا انت تستطيع
هذه الصواريخ
الصوت لذلك لا اعلم ما فعله استخدام هذه
الصواريخ عاليه التكلفه
ينفقوا اموالهم ولكننا لا نخشى هذا اذا
وجدت هذه الصواريخ في اوكرانيا سوف تطير
لها صواريخ فرصه صوتيه باسرع وقت همم
ان
تدريب اي خبراء للعمل على هذه الانظمه
يحتاج عده سنوات لذلك انا متاكد ان هذه
الصواريخ سوف يعمل عليها الخبراء
الامريكيين همم عليكم ان تفهموا هنا ان
السيد بوتين تحدث
عن اننا سوف نغير العقيده العسكريه
الروسيه سوف
الى العقيده الامريكيه التي تحت تحت
الباقيه قد نغير عقيدتنا العسكريه في هذه
الحلقه
السباقيه وهذا هو ما يمكن ان تتطور اليه
حرب
وليام فعلا اذا كانت هذه الصواريخ تحتاج
وقت واذا كانت لن تصيب كل الاهداف همم هل
هل الاعلان عن ارسالها لاوكرانيا هو همم
يعني من باب الضغط النفسي على بوتن للجلوس
للتفاوض اذا كان هناك صعوبات كثيره
ميدانيه في استخدامها ونقلها
وتدريب الناس الاوكرانيين عليها وتحديد
الاهداف وعلو ثمنها ما الرساله التي
ارادتها واشنطن ان تصل موسكو بالاعلان عن
هذه الخطوه
واه يا ابن ليس لدي معلومات انا لست ضمن
هذه المحادثات في واشنطين ولكنه نقطتين
اولا هذه المنظمات الدفاعيه فقط
سحريا فما تعلمون فهي موجوده
التي تريد
تقدم لها المساعده باي طريقه
ضد ضد السيارات
نوع من القوه
المتميزه لانها منظومه جيده ضد بعض اهدافه
ليست سحريه
وليمفالا قائد القائد اللي وصل الامريكيه
السابق وقائد الاسطول الخامس الامريكي
السابق نعتذر لضيق الوقت ونشكر ضيفنا
بالموسكو اليكساندر ارتموند الخبير
العسكريه
[موسيقى]
في محافظه الحسكه الشماليه السوريه سيرت
تركيا وروسيا دوريات المشتركه لاول مره
منذ اسابيع شهد قصف جوليا ومدفعيا على
مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
واعت ذلك بعد ايام قليله من اتصالات روسيه
تركيه على اعلى المستويات ومن تركمانستان
دعاء الرئيس التركي جميع الاتراك وفي
مقدمتها الولايات المتحده الى وقف الدعم
لما سماها المنظمات الارهابيه محضرا من
قيام بلاده بما يلزم للدفاع عن نفسها على
حد تعبيره في حاله مواصله دعم هذه المنظمه
مرحله اخرى لاداره ازمه الشمال السوري بين
موسكو انقره سير الدوريات المشتركه لقوات
البلدين في قرن خاضعه للسيطره ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمالي الحسكه
في الدوريات تكون وجهه نظر الرئيسين رضوان
تقربت بشان هذا الملف المتشابك تحدث
الراسان هاتفيه لاحد الماضي قبل وبعد
الاتصال لم تتوقف اللجان المشتركه بين
البلدين التابعه للخارجيه والدفاع في
التواصل من اجل خفض التوتر على الحدود
التركيه السوريه من تركمانستان رسائل
الرئيس اردوغان للدعيمين لما تعرفوا بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه كانت محضره ومهدده بان
واحد دعى جميع الاطراف وفي مقدمتها واشنطن
الى قطع الدعم عما سماها المنظمات
الارهابيه مؤكدا ان تركيا ستقوم بما يقع
على عاتقها في حال استمرار هذا الدعم كان
البنتاجون اعلن قبل ايام قليل استئناف
الدوريات المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده
وما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه بعد
تعليقها بسبب الضربات الجويه التركيه في
العشرين من نوفمبر الماضي اطلقت انقر
سلسله ضربات جويه استهدفت مواقع لحزب
العمال الكردستاني في العراق وايضا
الفصائل الكرديه في سوريا
اعتبرته الرد المناسبه على تفجير شارع
الاستقلال في اسطنبول ضربت الجويه والقصف
المدعي استمر رغم رفض موسكو حليفه النظام
دمشق وورشه الداعمه لبعض الفصائل الكرديه
في سوريا عمليات العسكريه ممثله كانت
الدبلوماسيه قد اوقفتها سابقا في 2019
اتفاق بين موسكو وانقره باخماد النيران
عمليه تركيه ونص على انشائي منطقه امنه
بعمق ثلاثين كيلومترا لحمايه التركيه من
هجمات قد تاتي من الارض السوريه
واقرت افاق اخر في السنه نفسها برعايه
واشنطن وموسكو على انسحاب القوات الكرديه
الى مسافه 30 كلم من الحدود التركيه بدا
ان تركيا تتهم روسيا والولايات المتحده
بعدم احترام الاتفاقيات وتقول انهما فشله
في ابعاد واحده حمايه الشعب عن حدودها
وتلويح اردوغان بعمليه
ورقه ضغط صالح للاستخدام في اكثر من ملفا
مع دمشق ومسكو مباشر الشمال السوري تحت
رحمه حسابات المعقده داخليا واقلاميا
وتوليا
نعود الى هذه الدوريات ونسال ضيف ففقره
المتابعه عن دلالاتها وفرص نجاحها في
تحقيق الاهداف المرجوه منها
[موسيقى]
في تونس تتجدد الدعوه لمقاطعه الانتخابات
التشريعيه بالتزاملي مع انطلاق التصويت في
الخارج وقبل يومين من توجه الناخبين داخل
البلاد الى مراكز الاقتراع في اخر المواقف
قال رئيس جبهه الخلاصه الوطني احمد نجيب
الشابي ان الجبهه تجدد مطالباتها بمقاطعه
الانتخابات وان حل الازمه لا يكون الا
بحوار وطني شامل
الى عامه المواطنين
بان يمسكوا عن المشاركه في انتخابات يوم
السبت
احنا نعرفه ان الشعب اليوم عازف عن
المشاركه ومعنا حتى شك ولا المواطنين
عندهم شك في النسبه لجد متدنيه
يوم السبت
تبادل المراقبه بين السلطات ديمقراطيه
صلاحياته التشريعيه يتشاجرها مع رئيس
الجمهوريه هذا هذا المجلس سيكون غرفه
تسجيل للاراده الاميريه في اطار دستور
ارسى الحكم الفردي المطلق كمان لم نعرفه
في الماضي
وكان رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قد رفض
الانتقالات الامريكيه لتوسيعه السلطاته
والقى باللوم على ما سماه الاخبار الزائفه
وقوه اجنبيه لم يسميها لانه
لانها تعارض حكمه كما يقول
وعلينا سعيد خلال اجتماع مع هيئه التحرير
صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان هناك لعديد من من
وصفهم باعداد ديمقراطيه في تونس يريدون
بذل كل ما بوسهم لنصف الحياه الديمقراطيه
والاجتماعيه للبلاد على حد تعبيره ودفع
الرئيس التونسيه بشده عن قراره تعليق عمل
البرلمان ويصدار دستور الجديد قال انه وفر
للتونسيين حقوقا وحمايه اكبر مقارنه مع
دستوريا 2014
ومن جهه اخرى قالت شبكه مراقبون ان
المساره الانتخابيه في تونس شابه خرق واضح
لمختلف المبادئ الاساسيه اوضح ممثل الشبكه
ان عمل الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
غلبت عليه الارتجاريه بعد اصدارها قرارات
وتنقيحات اثناء سير العمليه الانتخابيه
ثم سوء فهم والا فهم ارتاليه بالاخص لدى
الهيئه المصرف على الانتخابات وقال لي كل
مره تعطينا بقرار ولا بتلقيحات جديده وانت
في في في ضمن في عهده المعاهده الدوليه ما
تقولش على شيء هذه وهذه اللي خلانا احنا
عندنا برشا تحفظ وراهم مراقبون من عام
بالضبط معنى من خمسه من عام التالي اعطيني
كيفاش نكون تقسيم الدواء كيفاش اعتبر
العينه لكن للاسفنا ماشي معناها رد من
الهيئه وقاعده تخدم عادي
وفي المقابل قال فاروق بوعسكر رئيس الهيئه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات في تونس ان
الهيئه مستعده لاستقبال الناخبين في اكثر
من احد عشر الف مركز خارج البلاد وداخلها
واستعدادا اليوم
1485 مكتب اقتراع واربعه الاف 1692 مركز
اكتراب داخل البلاد وخارجها تتوزع على
11310 مكتب
40051 مركز داخل تراب الوطن 175 المكتب
141 مركز افتراء خارج حدود ارض الوطن في
الدوائر الانتخابيه بفرنسا وايطاليا تم
فتح باب التقديم الترشحات للانتخابات
اعضاء مجلس النواب من 17 اكتوبر 2020
تلقى خلال الايام حوالي
1427 مطلب ترشح تولى مجلس فيها واصدرنا
قائمه نهائيا للملفات المقبوله التي بلغ
عددها 1058 ملف
قال نواب الاوروبيون ان البرلمان
الاوروبيه لن يرسل اي بعثه لمراقبه
الانتخابات التونسيه المقرره يوم السبت
المقبل واضاف النواب ان القرار بشان تونس
صدر على ضوء قرار المحكمه الافريقيه لحقوق
الانسان وتقرير لجنه البندقيه واوضح
النواب ان قرار البرلمان الاوروبيه بعدم
مراقبه الانتخابات التونسيه جاء ايضا على
ضوء التطورات السياسيه والاجتماعيه في
تونس
معنا من تونس جمال مارس القيادي في حزب
التيار الشعبي ومعنى من تونس ايضا جوهر بن
مبارك الوطني
مساء الخير تحيه لكم والى كافه مشاهدي
قناه الجزيره طبعا هذه المحطه السياسيه
والانتخابيه الهام في تاريخ تونس تكتسب
واهميتها باعتبارها تنهى مسار 25 جويليه
وتدخل في مرحله جديده تاتي بنظام انتخابي
جديد وكذلك نظام سياسي جديد
ما تحدثت عنه في خصوص
الخارج وموقف رئيس الجمهوريه وردت الفعل
الامريكيه طبعا الفيديو الامريكي كان
مرفوع على مستوى رسمي منذ البدايه على
مسار 25 جويليه من خلال الخناقه المالي
الذي به السلطه السياسيه الحاليه ومحاوله
همم ارضاء هذه السلطه ربما لشروط
الامريكيه والتعامل بشكل يعني التعسفي
كبير همم شخصيه همم وما يهمنا حيث تيار
الشعبي ليس لاخر نحن نتوجه الى الشعب
التونسي ما يهمنا هو موقف المواطن التونسي
موقف داخل التونسي وما يتعلق بالسياده
قضيه وتكريس السياده الوطنيه واستقلاليه
القرار الوطني
وخصوص بعد اتحاد الاوروبي لا تعنين كثيرا
لان ما يهمنا هي ان تتم الانتخابات من
خلال هيئه مستقله هيئه عليا نؤكد مره اخرى
انها اكثر استقلاليه 100 مره من هيئه
السابقه وان ما يدعوه في خصوصيه عدم
استقلاليه تغنى معينه رز جمهوريه لا اساس
له من الصحه باعتبار هذا تضم الاعضاء
الذين سبق لهم وتحصلوا على التسريحات
اسمح لي هذا بها الى ضيفه
ايضا في تقرير واشنطن بوست عن هذا اللقاء
هنالك تصريحات لمسؤولين امريكيين في
الخارجيه الامريكيه
يقولون ان الولايات المتحده تدعم اجراء
هذه الانتخابات رغم همم التصريحات
العالميه من انترنت بلانكين وكان العالم
يتعامل مع امر واقع وان القطار يسير
وسيكون هنالك برلمان حينما تبدا بقت في
الداخل بعد يومين
لا الحقيقه مثلا لا تتعلق بوجود برلمان من
عدمه قيس عيد يحاول ان يؤسس بعض المؤسسات
ااه التابعه له واا يعيد هيكله همم
المؤسسات بشكل الذي يرضيه وعلى مقاسه ولكن
المثل لا تتعلق باجراء انتخابات وتنصيب
مجلس مجلس نيابي سوري المساله تتعلق بازمه
سياسيه خانقه تعيشها تونس وازمه اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه هذا هو ال- ال- هذه هي المعضله
بالنسبه للمنتظم الدولي
وان خرام الوضع السياسي والاقتصادي
والاجتماعي بشكل غير مسبوق في تونس همم
يهدد ايضا حتى امن المنطقه
والتوازنات الجيو الاستراتيجيه الموجوده
في المنطقه وخاصه همم امام الوضع الليبي
المتازم وتازم العلاقات المغربيه
الجزائريه كل هذا يجعل المنطقه الحساسه
جدا
وتوجهات قيس سعيد وعدم قدرته على مسك
البلاد وعدم قدرته على تجاوز الازمات
السياسيه وايجاد الصيغ القادره على حل
المشاكل السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
هو الذي يخلق هذه الوضعيه المعقده المثل
لا تتعلق تقنيا باجراء انتخابات ومحاوله
اعطاء انطباع بان قيس سعيد يتقدم في
اجندته الانتخابيه او في اجننتته السياسيه
هو في الحقيقه
كلها ما زاد من تعليق الازمه وكل ما زاد
من استفحال الازمه دور السياسي ليس في
تعميق الازمات وانما
وخاصه ان كان هذا سياسي مسؤول على راس طيب
همم الدوله وهنا نطرح سؤال على ضيف ايضا
جمال مارس لا ننسى ان الاجراءات قيس سعيد
في الاساس كانت استجابه همم كما يقول لي
صعوبه اقتصاديه وجوها المواطن التونسي هذه
الصعوبات زادت في عهده وتزيد بل هنالك
نبوءات متشائمه بشان الاقتصاد التونسي
وهذلك من يتحدث عن عدم قدره البلاد على
استعداد الديون همم ففي ما نجح اذا اذا
كان مساره لم يحقق للمواطن ما كان يصبو
اليه وما غضب بشانه من ما تسميه دائره قيس
سعيد بالعشريه السوداء
رئيس الصعيد اقدم على قرار 25 جويليه بوضع
حد للعشرين السواد والخراب وهو يدرك ان
حركه الاخوان ومن حكى مع معها خلال عشريه
اساس السوداء قد حطب الاقتصاد الوطني من
خلال اغراق الاقتصاد
بالقروض المتتاليه من صندوق النقد الدولي
وكذلك من خلال الماليه العموميه
بالتعويضات هذا كان يدركها منذ البدايه
وصار 25 جويلا هل هو مسار سياسي بالدرجه
الاولى اما اقتصادي واجتماعي كذلك هو مسار
سياسي باسيس وهو بغايته اعاده هيكله
النظام السياسي والنظام الانتخابي مؤسسات
الديمقراطيه السياديه فعليه تكرر سياده
الشعب ثم عن ترتب على استقبال هذا المسار
لا يمكن لقيس سعيد ان يبني في سنه او سنه
ونصف اقتصاد جديد ومن وين تنوي من جديد
ولسه المؤسسات غيبه والاقتصاد اقتصاديه
الذي غيره
كيا سي في الاساس وغيرته استقبال مؤسسات
الدوله من خلال يوم بعد غد استكمال
البرلمان ثم هذا البرلمان عندما يكون فيها
مواطنين ونواب يمثلون الرياض الوطنيه
والثقلين قال الوطني سيبنى استقلال سيبنى
اقتصاد وطني سيبنيع من يقع التكريز بن
وائل تنمو من جديد عندها يمكن الحديث على
الاقتداء على الانقاذ الاقتصادي والاجتماع
الاقتصاد الوطني اما تركه الثقيله لا يمكن
الحديث على خاصه معه التحالف همم رائع
السياسي والاقتصادي من اجل مجيد الاحتكار
ضربه اقتصاد الوطني هذا كل ااه كان مفترس
صديق الخلاق بالاضافه الى الخلاق الخارجي
والحكومه الحاليه حتى
25 ريال في ظل غياب ضغوط حقيقيه دوليه ما
الذي يمكن ان تفعله وانتم لتغيير المسار
الذي لا يعجبهم في تونس همم الرئيس حل
البرلمان همم استفت على الدستور صحيح
الذين صوتوا ثلث همم قوائم الناخبين او
اقل لكن هنالك دستور الان وها هو مقدم على
انتخابات برلمانيه همم لم تستطيعوا طوال
العام والنصف الماضيه ايقاف اي خطوه من
هذه الخطوات
لا المساله تتعلق بوضع تونس وليس بوضع
المعارضه او بوضع قيس سعيد الان تونس
وشعبها يتعرضون الى مخاطر جمه همم الوضعيه
تزداد وتدهورا يوم بعد يوم بعد يوم همم
هذا الاسبوع لم يكن اسبوع عن جيدا همم
بالنسبه
لقيس سعيد فشله عندما ذهب الى السعوديه في
جلب اي دعم همم في المؤتمر همم الصيني
العربي فشل في زيارته الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وترك انطباعا سيئا جدا
سواء لدى المسؤولين الامريكيين اولى ده
الراي العام الامريكي والصحافه
الامريكيه ثم الخبر المزلزل الذي نزل على
سلطه الانقلاب عندما اعلن صندوق النقد
الدولي سحب تونس من روزنامه اجتماعاتها
همم الثانويه اللي كانت مبرمجه في 19 من
هذا الشهر هذا يعني ان انغلاق شديد وفوق
الماليه للبلاد و فاتوره ايضا باهظه
سيدفعها الشعب التونسي اضافيه اعتقد ان
قيس سعيد يقود البلاد الى الانهيار الشامل
ويجب ان نقف الى تونس وكل شعب يجب ان يقف
وليس المعارضه فقدت هذه ليست مسؤوليه
المعارض فقط هذه مسؤوليتكم تونسيه ان يقف
لتونس حتى يمنع هذا الانهيار الشامل الذي
تسبب فيه قيس سعيد
في حرق جبهه الخلاص الوطني وايضا جمال
مارس القيادي في حزب التيار الشعبي شكرا
لكم
اذا يتواصل الجدر في تونس قبل يومين من
الانتخابات التشريعيه التي دعا اليها
الرئيس قيس سعيد كيف بدات هذه الازمه وما
هي ابرز محطاتها في الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو تموز 2021 وقال الرئيس قيس سعيد
الحكومه وجمد البرلمان والغى الدستور وحكم
البلاد بالمراسيل تحرك سعيد نحو السلطه
القضائيه فمنح نفسه في ال 23 من فبراير
شباط الماضي السلطه طلعوا لي على القضاه
وحل مجلس القضاء الرافدين لقرارات الرئيس
اعلنوا في الخامس والعشرين من ابريل نساء
الماضي تاسيس جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه لمواجهه
مشروع سعيد وتضم الهيئه وعددا من الاحزاب
والمنظمات والحركات السياسيه والحقوقيه في
الاول من يوليو تموز الماضي طرح قيس سعيد
دستور الجديده للاستفتاء وهي خطوه عارضتها
الاحزاب في البلاد واتهمت الرئيس بالسعر
والتركيز السلطات في يده
لكن في السادس عشر من سبتمبر الماضي اصدر
الرئيس قانون جديد للانتخابات رفضته
الاحزاب ودعت جبت الخلاص المواطني لمقاطعه
الانتخابات التي تجرى بموجب هذا القانون
اما في الخامسه عشر من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي فقد وقعت تونس اتفاقا اوليا مع
صندوق النقد الدولي للحصول على حزمه انقاذ
مالي مشروطه باصلاحات ترفضها العديد من
القوه التونسيه
غير بعيد من تونس قال رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه الليبيه عبد الحميد باي بان
مسؤوليه الدوله في ملف الاكربي انتهت
تماما بعد ثمن الباهض الذي دفعته ليبيا
وبعد دفع التعويضات لاهالي الضحايا واضافت
بيبه في كلمه المسجله انه لن يسمح بفتح
ملف لقربي من جديد
قد اقفل تماما ليس بسبب الحنكه السياسيه
ولا التحديات والشعارات ولكن بسبب
المليارات التي دفعت انذمهم للمحاكمه في
الخارج
واعترف امام مجلس الامن بالمسؤوليه عن
الجريمه بعد انكار دام 15 سنه
لذلك بعد كل هذا الثمن الباهض
لن اسمح اليوم بفتح ملف لوكربي من جديد
من اعمال القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه
الرئيس الامريكي ضد الى الانضمام انضمام
الاتحاد الافريقي الى مجموعه الدول
العشرين بشكل دائم وقال ان بلاده تدعم
بشكل كامل لاصلاح مجلس الامن الدولي حتى
يشمل عضويه دائمه للاتحاد بالمجلس
سبتمبر الماضي في جمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده ان الولايات المتحده تدعم بالكامل
اصلاح مجلس الامن ليشمل التمثيل الدائمه
لافريقيا اليوم ادعوا ايضا لانضمام
الاتحاد الافريقي الى مجموعه العشرين كعضو
دائما كان يجب ان يحدث ذلك منذ وقت طويل
لكنه سيحدث شعوب افريقيا شركاء لا غنى
عنهم لتحقيق المكاسب ليس فقط لافريقيا
والولايات المتحده وانما للعالم باسره
حضرت السفاره الامريكيه في الاردن رعاياها
من السفر الشخصيه والرسميه لا مده جنوب
البلاد السينما الكرك والطفيله ومعان
والعقبه حتى اشعار اخر هذا التحذير في وقت
تستمر فيه الاحتجاجاته في عدد من المدن
الاردن بالتزامن مع اضراب الذي نفذه سائق
الشاحنات وعاملون في القطاع قطاع النقل
والشحن احتجاجا على الارتفاع المستمر
باسعار المحروقات اذا اغلقت المحل
التجاريه ابوابها اليوم الثاني على
التوالي في مدينتين معان والكرك كما شهدت
احياء في العاصمه عمان وقفات تضامنيه مع
المدربين رغم العوده النسبيه لحركه الشحن
في البلاد
تظاهر الاف من انصار المعارضه التركيه في
اسطنبول احتجاجا على حكم بالسجن في حق
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو ردد
المشاركون الشعارات تتهم الحزب الحاكم
بتسييس القضاء وكانت محكمه قد قضت
الاربعاء بالسجن عامين وسبعه اشهر على
امام اوغلو بتهمه الاساءه لاعضاء هيئه
الانتخابات عام 2019
نظمت الرقم التمريض في بريطانيا اضرابها
عن العمل هو الاكبر في البلاد منذ نحو قرن
للمطالبه بتحسين الاجور والظروف العمل
وانضم الى اللي ضرب قرابه 100,000 من
العاملين في مهنه التمريض وقد رفضت حكومه
المحافظين مطالبه نقابه التمريض بزياره
الاجور بحوالي 99%
ال 8:00 صباحا درجه الحراره وسط لندن
قرابه السادسه تحت الصفر لكن هذا لم يمنع
هؤلاء الممرضين والممرضات المطربين عن
العمل من الوقوف لتسجيل اعترافهم على موقف
الحكومه من مطالبهم موقفا تراهم نقابه
التمريض متغطرسه
انهم يرفضون التفاوض معي يدخلونني الى
غرفه ويقولون انه يمكنني التحدث عن اي شيء
الا الاجور
عرضت الحكومه زياده اجور تواقم التمريض
بنحو اربعه في المئه وقد زادت بالفعل اجور
قطاع الصحه كله العام الماضي بنحو ثلاثه
في المئه ارقام يراها المطربون هزيله في
زمن فاق فيه معدل التضخم احد عشر في المئه
ويقولون ان مطلبهم بزياده تبلغ 19% سببه
ان اجورهم لم تزد بشكل مناسب خلال عشر
سنوات
اخرى قال الاضراب مئات المستشفيات في عموم
بريطانيا باستثناء اسكتلندا التي الغي
الاضراب فيها بعد اتفاق الحكومه والنقابه
على معدل زياده الاجور ويوضح الممرضون ان
مطالبهم لا تقتصروا على الاجور
الخلاف مستمر اذا حتى شعار اخر وكذلك
تستمر معاناه المتضررين من المرضى
الممرضين تزامنا مع احتجاجات اجتماعيه
عديده اخرى ومع انذارات باضرابات من قبل
عمال السكك الحديديه وفئه اجتماعيه ومهنيه
اخرى ويبدو انها جلدتها هذه الاضطرابات مع
اقتراب يا اعياد الميلاد ستؤثر على حياه
البريطانيين وتثير تساؤلات بشان التفاوض
بين حكومه المحافظين والنقابات اسد الله
الصاوي الجزيره لندن
نعود الى خبر استئناف في تركيا وروسيا
الدوريات المشتركه في الشمال السوري حيث
نصلي الضوء اكثر على سياق هذه الدوريات
وابعادها ومرجعيتها مذكره التفاهم الروسيه
التركيه الموقعه في اكتوبر 2019
لسيطره الوحدات الكرديه التي تعتبرها انقر
ذراع حزب العمال الكردستاني
امل منطقه المتبقيه وهي بعمق 10 كم من خط
الحدود فتؤمنها دوريات عسكريه تركيه
وروسيه المشتركه بمقتضى اتفاقيه سوشي وفي
البدء كانت الدوريات المشتركه تتخذ اربعه
مساره اساسيه ابرزها في الريفين الشرقي
والغربي
لمدينه عين العرب كوباني بمحافظه حلب ثم
ياتي استئناف الدورات المشتركه في سياق
جهود لتفادي العمليه العسكريه البريه التي
اعلنت تركيا انها ستنفذها ضد مواقع ما
تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في مناطقه
شمالي سوري
التعامد العسكري التركي في شمال شرق سوريا
لم يكن سلسا في كل الاوقات حيث توقفت هذه
الدوريات عده مرات اخر دوريه مشتركه بين
القوات الروسيه والروسيه التركيه والروسيه
تم تسريرها يوم الرابعه عشر من نوفمبر
الماضي
عموما سجل العام الحالي انخفاضا في معدل
تسيير الدوريات المشتركه حيث لم تتعدى
ثلاثه دوريات شهريه مقابله نحو سته وستين
دوريه مشتركه العام الماضي بمعدل اكثر من
خمس دوريات في الشهر
اما اول ودوريه المشتركه بين تركيا وروسيا
فكانت قبل ثلاث سنوات وتحديدا في الاول من
نوفمبر عام
2019 لنقاش اكثر في هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اذا استولفت
الدوريات المشتركه في الحسكه بين تركيا
وروسيا ما الذي يعني ذلك
يعني هو نوع من التناغم مع التوجه السياسي
الجديد الرئيس اردوغان قبل سنوات كان يرفض
بصوره مطلقه
مجرد الحديث عن الالتقاء بالرئيس الاسد
قبل عده اشهر كان هناك تلميحات ثم حدث
اجتماعات امنيه اليوم
يتحدث صراحه بانه تحدث مع الرئيس الروسي
عن احتماليه عقد لقاء ثلاثي روسي سوري
تركي وان كان مشروطا باربعه مراحل
وباتخاذ اجراءات من الجانب السوري ان يكون
اجتماع لقياده الاجهزه الامنيه وزراء
الدفاع وزراء الخارجيه ومن ثم لقاء القمه
او لقاء القادم ولكن ذلك يعتمد على بعض
الطلبات محاربه الارهاب ابتعاد قوات اسد
الى غير ذلك اذا هناك تحول في اتجاه ضوء
البوصله التركيه تجاه الازمه اييه السوريه
لماذا لان هل هذا يعني ان العمليه البريه
التي ترفضها واشنطن وتتحفظ عليها موسكو
والنظام السوري وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
او مطار القدس الدينارديه تم التخلي عنها
لا هو لم يتم التخلي عنها لا يزال هناك
التلويح بها في هذا اليوم كان هناك قصف
وقريب من عين العرب وفي بعض المناطق
الاخرى دعني اقول له قلنا منذ البدايه بان
العمليه البريه لا يمكن ان يتم تنفيذها
دون ضوء اخضر امريكي اولا روسي ثانيا
ايراني ثالثا الدول الثلاث
مواقفه متباينه الموقف الامريكي يرفض
بالمطلق اي عمليه ضمن منطقه مسؤوليه
القوات الامريكيه الموقف الروسي لا اكثر
ليونه
وقدم بعض العروض التي رفضت منها الانسحاب
17 كيلو متر في منطقه عين العرب كوباني
همم الانسحاب من تل رفعت الى الشيخ مقصود
من منطقه
بهذه العمليه ما زال مستمرا رغم كل هذه
التحفظات نشكركم من عمان اللواء فايز
الدولي الخدري العسكري
وصلنا لنهايه فقره امر هذا الحصاد شكرا
لحسن المتابعه
[موسيقى]